well I kinda loved about this film is I
thought when I was watching it this is
actually make the ultimate reality TV
show I think I reminded me of like maybe
like the Kardashians like Dumbledore's
kinda like Kris Jenner welcome back to
kawan meet Josh in taste and today we're
joined by the fantastic beast cars guys
how are you if you guys were gonna do a
YouTube tutorial in witchcraft what
would it look like and what would it
contain it would be very minimal and
would remain surface layer because you
have to be really careful with the power
yeah you know you want to go out and do
like a moon ritual or something like
that you know and like been like go out
in the rain and naked which I've never
done before but that online tutorial
sounds x-rated and also it's my least
parental advisory with it no I loved
about this film is I thought when I was
watching it this is actually make the
ultimate reality TV show really I think
I reminded me of like maybe like the
Kardashians like Dumbledore's kinda like
Kris Jenner yeah which is their show
yeah who's the person who just refreshed
like controls the whole show yeah yeah
like [ __ ] anyway in a different way Ring
of Fire by the way the other day Danny
Dyer who is my favorite he won't
necessarily know if he didn't watch the
most recent but she was she was nice
about me on telly and it just she made
my oh my god whoa yeah literally
nation's hero what you think's the
ultimate spell chop line
well is it with you and then Jude your
kind of Dumbo licious in this night and
then I was reading the Twitter feedback
about when you got announced on your
casting what's the funniest one you
[Music]
unleash your inner beast now you were
singing yourself you don't even know
about the Christmas album you know oh I
don't know if you're allowed to know
about it mm-hmm that's coming yeah
Michael Buble yo ha
Levon Ava if you guys look at that
create a song or do like a duet just sum
up the relationship of your characters
what would you do you have to be like X
we'd have to do like an egg song like
welder message in my kiss which is a
great punk duo yeah we're kind of punk
rock you know work maledictis you know
in a certain sense I mean maledicte is
to you card breakers